welcome to this yeah yeah in this video
I'll present you a very interesting rook
endgame which just had been played today
so it's a very fresh game the last moves
have been played about two hours ago
and this was in a team match that I'm
played today in the German league um
it's not one of my games I played myself
but my game was really a rather
uneventful opponent played the opening
very badly but I reacted also in the
wrong way and there's actually instead
of giving me a clear advantage that
pretty much fizzled out immediately into
a draw position and yeah not much
happened really so I'll show you another
game fragment from this match and the
players here are from the white side
this is from our opponents team the
opposing team Lawrence webbie's and
feeder master from Great Britain but
playing here Germany I think he also
lives in Germany so um he's around to
270 or something rated and the black
players my teammate Intl massa count
he's rated to 370 to 360 something like
this and we look at the game starting
from this position here the rugged game
in fact the game was rather rather tense
affair where White's had missed um clear
winds and the in the middle game let's
say but it was some time trouble so just
I don't know six or seven months ago
white could have won rather easily it's
even a first mate at some point but it
wasn't so easy to do with them just very
little time on the clock but white at
the end reach this endgame we have here
move 45 Black has just captured upon on
d7 and yeah let's assess this
came of course what you immediately
notice is why does upon up four against
three and this is the main point um why
does got two connected passes on the
queenside to connect the pass bonds so
I'm in general in the rook endgame two
connected passed pawns should win the
game
it's very reality that they don't win
but um we see in this this game here
that you still need to be very alert to
counter play and it also shows very
nicely this game that you need to try to
fight in rocket games because there are
simply a very wide drawing margin there
are many possibilities to continue the
game and yeah look for chances
the first important move actually is
coming here right away why does to move
and he's playing rugby 5 which is fine
white wants to use the a point first and
this way pushes pawn so this is
perfectly alright um here black has two
principal ideas in fact the computer
shows the move King to d6 which whitey
made didn't play and I think rightly so
the computer wants to use the King in
sort of defense again this pawns but
this is simply the wrong approach it
might have the better evaluation for the
computer initially but at the end this
is bound to fail it's simply too passive
but let's look at a simple line what
would happen of course white would push
his pawns which is very very easy like
it doesn't have much else to to give a
check here and get behind the pawns to
have some slight chance to stop them and
now white can try to activate his King
he can activate his scheme because black
didn't push any parts on the King side
it might continue just to to show what
happens whiter
must be willing to sacrifice a pawn here
to be able to push the a pawn just a
sample line you see that white can
really make progress here so it's the
check on b7 what should like do probably
move ahead so we can really look at this
this pawns are simply they're simply too
strong it's still a couple of moves that
you could try black and try to use some
his pawns as well but white can simply
ignore this because his bones are simply
a simply quicker in the end here we get
a very basic basic endgame um King C 5 P
6 H 5 like and try that and cannot take
here because of the pawns so you get at
the end this kind of endgame f3 takes
here F 2 and now white will catch the F
pawn and did something like this at the
end where whites will win with the saved
V with is H born this is the very
faraway pawn and blacks king is simply
too too bad his cut off and what we'll
simply push this pawn to promotion this
is of course a very long line it's just
meant to show that you need to really
generate counter play quickly and in the
game black played g5 which is certainly
the better move you must push your pawns
here to get something going
I mean objectively this position is lost
anyway but you need to find and the only
way to fight us to use all your all your
units so to say all pawns of the king
must be activated if possibly if
possible and this is why you need to
push the pawn
yeah why 25 which is fine age five a-six
rookie one check booking edge - by the
way wide also had the chance to to play
this a tad slower if you if you wish
just play move like King G one and get
out of this this is also a very viable
option probably the the simpler one even
but what he did is it's perfectly
alright than a six check
Andrew k1 so black has activated his
rook this rook now controls the first
rank and stopped the a palm so this is
already a successful black that he
managed to get the the pieces active
white gets a check here and basically
the only move to keep the pond but in
the process likes King has been
activated also so now black has some
definite counter play f/4g form and
there's something happening and it's
even mating ideas in in some lines I'm
here white played the move before and in
fact this move while not spoiling
anything yeah okay let's say I'm I
looked at at much mess sheet here wrong
of course I prepared something
this move is fine actually I will just
want to show an alternative if white
wants to attack this pawn rook g6 just
want to show this quickly black pushes
g4
before also note that if white tries to
move like g3 giving some some room for
the king then
like it goes here and detects the b-pawn
so g3 is not really a move that helps
too much you can continue this but it's
obvious that rope g6 to b6 good back
didn't didn't help too much like simply
is activating the king and this way
should should get the draw let's say
here this idea and black has enough
counter place simply White has no moves
he cannot move this pawn he cannot move
this so he's basically tied all around
rook g6 is simply not a good move he
played before now passed pawns must be
pushed
okay good rule which I'm almost always
supplies and now King F oh no you see if
black would have two moves his checkmate
yeah of course White has ways to prevent
this but this is some real town to play
and White needs to be cautious not to
allow anything in fact in the game in
this position he played the move rook to
c6 but this is maybe not the decisive
mistake but it would have been much
quicker to play b5 and also clearer
the idea being b5 g 4 there's nothing
else you need to push takes takes and
now the move rook g6 which prevents this
g3 idea and after this some yeah why
does winning we can look at rook a5 as
the last idea attacking the pawn but
then white simply pushes because here at
the pawn promotes so the only idea would
be this move rook takes rook a6 and now
rook b3 and now we've got
the rook behind the past past pawn and
this is a pretty pretty simple win with
white now coming around and he will pick
up the F pawn note that oops rook b8 he
shouldn't play this we see this position
on the side can can get that from the
medic it's checkmate
but white simply goes here and what
should like do we can only stay here
with the Skinit he will win the F pawn
or advanced with his King Black has no
play at all with the roof being tied
down to the b-pawn so here b5 for the
one he played rook c6 however the idea
of using the rook for defense of course
g4 this was the idea why it took and
here's the last the absolutely last
position where white could could have
yet tried to win the game really it's um
g3 the main threat I want to put it on
this lot just one student to show it
this is the mate so white cannot simply
push the pawn or make any kind of
nothing move he is so cool of the pledge
rope to success it's a tempo down with
the beep horn but still white threatens
to push the pawn the only idea that like
now has is to give this check there's
nothing else takes here rook here and
then white can play it a similarly to to
go behind the something like this let me
put it on the board okay get to this
position which is similar to the one
before except for the fact that it was
two rows some deck the rook wasn't be at
the pond of e7 so this is not as good
but wide sir retains winning chances I
think it's probably probably win still
but
it's not entirely easy but this this
retains winning chances at least in the
game the white player here gave this
cheque with g3 and after this it's
definitely a draw King III and now we
see blacks idea he wants to give a
perpetual check so the combination of
King pawn and rook is enough to set up a
petrol check and yeah white still needs
to cover the a pawn and yeah what should
he do now he simply a.m. has no good way
to keep his material and also prevent
the perpetual so something let's say
King here it's just perpetual check yeah
so I'm what he tried is he gave this
cheque like went back note that if you
go here this is this is worse maybe it's
even maybe even that is enough the idea
is the following let's say b5 and then
this move our lattice you can take this
you could take a black and play here
maybe white still cannot really push the
pawns and yeah it's difficult to make
any progress
if white plays let's say rook b3 then
you can give this check and just and
just stay you go here you ran into a
very nice checkmate again again the game
this check was played and maybe even
King f2 was ok but it's much simpler
water my teammate played he just played
King to d4 attacking the rook and this
is something more forcing as now
of course the porn is hanging and if
white oops
if white covers it then King III is just
a repetition this position we had before
my white gave this cheque and and you've
got this idea of a perpetual yeah so in
the game you went he M taking this pawn
but now black can simply take a six and
this is of course very important to get
rid of one of those pawns this
protective passed pawns you're connected
passed pawns are protected sorry
yeah white took on a five and now check
again and the King so you need to go for
maximum activity no passive moves please
everything needs to be active in the
rock endgame and here black has this
check ideas again but he also has the
idea to simply get behind the pawn and
this way attacking it while the white
king is still cut off so um this is
simply the best move whiter now played
rook to f4 we can look at an alternative
let's say b5 rugby - and what should
white play now this is quite funny he
needs to stay on the fifth rank to keep
this protected but if you stay on the
fifth rank and say look here then after
this move black simply gets the Jeep on
and okay it's still a draw but why does
certainly not in a position to try
anything here he even needs to be a bit
careful so you cannot push the b-pawn
really he tried as mentioned rook F on
then simply here and it's again a
position where white doesn't really have
anything decent he needs to give up the
F force they have three square to allow
the King to take the pawn oh he needs to
give up the pawn so he took here and
King f3
yeah and now
like get this pawn or this pawn and both
this is a complete draw it played rook
g8 we can also have a brief look at this
move
yeah then black can simply take the pawn
threatening checkmate and
let's say here like simply approaches
the pawn and will we win it so what's so
completely dead in the game
oops this was a bit of quick in the game
I'm quite sure what the program is doing
here
yeah rook GA t plate and now roof checks
before yeah and now black has really a
complete and dead draw and in fact the
Jeep horn is the worst pawn to have if
you try to win this kind of endgame the
additional problem with the Jeep on is
that even the most passive defense
draws we can continue this fall for some
moves this is what what has been played
and now black simply in this kind of
position stayed on the fixed rank but
the problem here is really even if white
makes a maximum progress I mean besides
black blundering rook scent and stuff
even then it's still a draw we can look
at the following let's say what play G
for here and let's say black sets up the
most passive position you can think of
look back and all the way back to g8 so
the most passive position you can think
of and here white has no way whatsoever
to make any progress black simply plays
for the rest of the game
the rook on the eighth-ranked on those
five squares according to me my troop
position of course cannot be okayed you
just stay on these five squares until
hell freezes over and you make it wrong
what cannot do anything he can try to
advance his stuff here yeah and there's
no way to make any progress the problem
is if this all would be on the on the F
file then you've got rook aged seven but
your cage seven you have no check here
like simply stays and white cannot make
any progress at all he can give various
checks whatnot it's it's simply not a
not winning note that if you tried this
move attending with h8 you even losing
the game so this is a useful thing to
remember if you are fighting against G
porn you can really set up the most
passive defense and it's still a draw of
course the most common way to draw these
kind of positions as you look at this
position King here is the sixth ranked
offense the Philidor defense where black
simply stays on the six rank with his
rook and waits until white plays g6
because he cannot advance the King the
rook is setting this barrier and in the
moment Y plays g6 you go all the way
back and now give check see on the back
rank and it's it's simply a draw white
can do all kinds of stuff and now you
start checking and so on it's simply
it's simply a draw so on the important
thing to to take from this game is look
at this position you shouldn't lose hope
in such end games you must play as
actively as possible and use the things
you have in this position here G pawn H
pawn activate all your pieces and try
for countable
it's not so important that you're
materially down it's the activity that
counts
I mean even if black would need to
sacrifice a pawn to get a little bit of
activity he would probably do that of
course it still was winning but it look
here here b5 this was the only really
completely winning move and yeah the
wild player not just not a weak player
by any means it didn't manage to do it
in limited time he was all you need to
need to take this into consideration the
time is limited in the tournament game
especially also in a rabid game or
whatever and it's um simply more
difficult to defend against some active
player the opponent than sitting
passively so I'm just play active in the
Luke endgame this is really the utmost
importance
yeah the the most important rule in the
route can't came to to play active
actively alright I hope you enjoyed this
the Saint game hope you got something
out of it
and yeah talk to you soon with new
videos